foreign
hey John welcome to the show
hey
hey how can we help
I have some questions about the
Financial Peace University
I'm really interested in it and my wife
is very skeptical
tell us about her skepticism
well you know there's so many online
influencers that she just thinks she
just thinks it's all a scam oh
what what kind of scam are we running
here John I'm curious well how does she
Define
I don't know I'm really interested in
the Financial Peace University I was
wondering if I could hear a few more
things about it well I'll tell you this
uh most scams out there for online
courses all involve you making a lot of
money really fast get rich quick right
right we promised get rich really slow
so it's kind of like the opposite of a
scam because it actually involves you
doing hard work and us doing uh very
little other than telling you that you
can do it and showing you the path and
so this is simply uh this online course
was something Dave Ramsey has been doing
for 30 years now 10 million people have
gone through Financial Peace University
they've changed their family tree by
getting out of debt and Building Wealth
and none of it involved some sneaky
investment thing it was just hey you
paid to go through a course one time and
then we gave you the tools to go do it
I want to hear more and this may just be
my own curiosity but I want to hear more
about the scams that she's running into
so is it I mean obviously there might be
she has a she hasn't ran into any scams
she just thinks I'm crazy for listening
to things I hear online you know most of
the stuff we put out there is free and
so I don't know many scammers they're
like here's here's all our cards on the
table and if you want to go through this
course you can do that
so I mean I'm happy to gift it to you I
don't know if you were calling in hoping
to do that but hey you know I I'm happy
to gift it to you and your wife for free
so it involves zero dollars and we're
not gonna ask you for money later
there's no love offering at the end of
the nine weeks we just want to help
people build wealth and get out of debt
no I wasn't hoping for that I was truly
just curious she was curious and I'm
curious myself you know I just wanted to
know more about it the simplest way is
there's nine video lessons in there and
you can join a local class that are in
your community in the Kentucky area you
can find one online or you can go
through it at home on your own terms on
your own time and so you can watch each
lesson there's fill in the blanks
there's budgeting as a part of that
through every dollar our budgeting tool
that's included in that and each lesson
just covers a different topic and so we
start with kind of the framework we go
into getting out of debt having Savings
in the bank for emergencies investing
for the future we talk about insurance
we talk about generosity and so there's
a lot of basic principles in there this
is common sense stuff that you know God
and Grandma talk about and so there's
nothing in here that's going to like
blow your mind of like I didn't think
about it
it's the newest coolest Trend ever it's
the least trendy thing out there
well and John I would encourage you to
hop on Facebook we have a really active
baby steps community and you can see a
lot of people in there who are winning
who've done the steps who are the best
cheerleaders because they have literally
just committed to the process walked it
out and they're super successful in
their finances now and that's the
beautiful thing about Dave having 30
years of experience is that we you have
so many people who sell it for us now
because it's changed their lives I mean
the proof is in the pudding and I can't
believe I just said that that makes me
sound like I'm a hundred
but the proof is all these people who
are winning with money so I encourage
you to have her get on there and check
it out because it's like they'll tell
you they'll tell you why they won
they'll tell you how they were
successful and just be really excited
about it
thanks for calling yeah most games are
easy for the person you know they'd say
hey just give me some money I'll turn it
into I'll 10x your money by tomorrow our
plan is hey uh here's how to get out of
debt now you have to go sell the car and
work three jobs so that's like the worst
scam ever that we're running over here
and uh John since it's free I'll give
you your money back if it doesn't work
out for you how's that I feel like it
was a really good deal